>> Bret: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WE ARE JUST GETTING A
STATEMENT FROM VIRGINIA'S
GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM ABOUT
THIS CONTROVERSY.
THERE YOU SEE THE YEARBOOK
FROM 19 WILL 4.
HERE'S THE STATEMENT I WILL
JUST READ ALL OF IT FROM
GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM FROM
VIRGINIA.
EARLIER TODAY A WEBSITE
PUBLISHED A PHOTOGRAPH FROM
ME FROM MY 1948 MEDICAL
SCHOOL YEARBOOK IN A COSTUME
THAT IS CLEARLY RACIST AND
OFFENSIVE.
I'M DEEPLY SORRY FOR THE
DECISION I MADE TO APPEAR AS
I DID IN THIS PHOTO AND FOR
THE HURT THAT DECISION
CAUSED THEN AND NOW.
THIS BEHAVIOR IS NOT IN
KEEPING WITH WHO I AM TODAY
AND THE VALUES I HAVE FOUGHT
FOR THROUGHOUT MY CAREER IN
THE MILITARY, IN MEDICINE
AND IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR, I
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS DECISION
SHAKES VIRGINIAN'S FAITH IN
THAT COMMITMENT.
I RECOGNIZE THAT IT WILL
TAKE TIME AND SERIOUS EFFORT
TO HEAL THE DAMAGE THIS
CONDUCT HAS CAUSED.
I AM READY TO DO THAT
IMPORTANT WORK.
THE FIRST STEP IS TO OFFER
MY SINCEREST APOLOGY AND TO
STATE MY ABSOLUTE COMMITMENT
TO LIVING UP TO THE
EXPECTATIONS VIRGINIANS SET
FOR ME WHEN THEY ELECTED ME
TO BE THEIR GOVERNOR.
GOVERNOR NORTHAM, A
STATEMENT ON THIS PHOTO AND
THE YEARBOOK.
WEAVE COVERED IT AT THE TOP
OF THE SHOW AND OBVIOUSLY IN
THE WEEK IN WHICH HE ALSO
COMMENTED ON A LATE TERM